Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Conners and today we're going to be discussing your
gene profile.
So these are people that have done this gene profile and we're going to go over it together
your seed by computer screen here.
So hopefully this is, we're going to answer these questions when we go over this together.
So I'm not going to go over every single gene in this 23 and be test, but we're going to
go over some classifications of this.
It's taking a long time to go over these profiles with people, so I thought, well we need
a little bit more education here.
I know this is a learning curve and there's a lot to learn in trying to absorb it all in
one city that is difficult, that's why I thought putting together a video will be helpful
for everybody.
So let's go through this.
What are we looking for in these genes?
So this is everybody that's done the 23 and be profile and now have sent me the data and
once you've sent me the data, I put it in a little handy-dandy computer program and we
get a spit out that looks similar to this.
I just took little chunkets of this that you're going to get this sheet just like this.
That's going to be about 11, 12 pages long and we're going to look at each one of these
individual genes and I'm going to talk about these individual genes.
Now this is actually somebody's profile that I took their name off of.
So it's going to break it into different compartments, but before we get to that, I want to just
reiterate some of the things that I've already talked about just so you remember that when
we look at your genes, there's some things that you need to keep in mind.
Number one, just because I have a genetic defect, doesn't mean I'm going to necessarily have
a problem.
Genetic defects can be present in everybody, matter of fact, there isn't anybody that doesn't
have genetic single nucleotide polymorphisms and they can live to 120 years old and be
just fine.
Matter of fact, there's some SNP defects that can help prevent cancers that can help prevent
different things.
It can be beneficial given different environmental circumstances and there's some that could cause
some issues.
Now, all of them will cause more issues if there's environmental insults as well, beating
that if I'm never exposed to lime or harmful chemicals or H. Pallora or other bacteria or pathogens
etc., then my genes aren't going to really play a big part in my health.
However, if I have G defects plus I'm exposed to lime infection and I'm exposed to different
pathogens and I have heavy metal toxicity and I was exposed to mercury in my fillings, then
you have all these insults that lead to problems.
When we look at this genetic profile, it's important to understand that there are all sorts
of environmental things that play into my health and we take a look at the environmental things
plus the genetic issues and it can tell a picture that we can help us manage the patient.
So specifically when we look at this gene profile, we're looking at it says variants.
So in this picture, that little blue box, you can see my arrow here, we're looking at
the HLA gene and it says variants.
In this scenario, we're looking at that it says one here and none of them say two here because
this person only has a single allele defect in these genes or it doesn't have anything in
that box.
So that would mean that this person inherit the normal, what's called a wild gene from
his mother and from his father, meaning he doesn't have any defects.
In this first one where it says one, that means this person inherited either a defective
gene from his or her mother or his or her father.
So this person has a single allele defect.
So understand each one of these genes, this HLA gene for instance, can be a family of
genes.
In this case, there's a family of at least two genes that are measured here.
The FUT2 gene here is a family of three genes that are measured here.
Each one of the genes has two alleles, one from your father, one from your mother.
If I have zero defects, I can still have problems with the gene because of environmental insult.
If I have one defect, I could have more problems with the gene, given environmental insults.
If I have a double allele defect or two variants, I could have even more problems with the gene.
Still doesn't mean it's not going to work completely, but it means that I could have more problems
with it.
Alright, so let's jump into that so we have all those little caveats that you can remember.
So we look at the HLA genes.
Those are the genes that are known to affect gluten, meaning that if I have one of those genes
like this person as a single allele defect on an HLA gene, that means they're going to be
more prone to be susceptible to gluten intolerance.
So if this was you, and I said you have a single allele defect on your HLA gene, it would
be my suggestion that you go gluten-free if you're not already gluten-free.
If you don't have any defects on the HLA genes, does it mean you don't have to go gluten-free?
Again, the answer is no.
It would still be beneficial to go gluten-free because gluten is inflammatory.
So if you have genetic defects of the HLA gene, it's even more important to be gluten-free.
Follow me.
So if a person was gluten-free already and they show no defects on the HLA genes, the correct
thing to do is to stay gluten-free.
If the person is not gluten-free and they have some defects on the HLA gene, then it's even
more important that they go gluten-free.
Follow me.
So the genes aren't the tell-tale for everything.
The genes just give us an indication of what's going on.
You'll understand it better as we continue.
The second digestive factor gene is your FUT2 genes.
Your FUT2 genes help make the slime layer for a better sake of a better term that coats
your intestinal walls.
So everybody knows about your flora of your intestines, and you need to take probiotics
so that your intestines have a good healthy probiotic layer, so you have that symbiotic
environment of microbes that help you digest things and absorb things and kill off and fight
off pathogens.
So we take probiotics, that's helpful.
Well, that's good, but where did the probiotics live?
Well, they live in the gut.
Well, where did they live in the gut?
They live in the healthy slime layer that coats the intestinal walls.
That healthy slime layer is made by the epithelial cells themselves through a process using
this FUT2 gene.
So if a person has a defect like this individual, has a single allele defect, it all three
of those FUT2 genes, that's not so good.
So they are going to have more difficulty making the apartment complex for the probiotics
to live in.
So this could be a person, and if this is you, you could be taking all the probiotics in
the world and you can't figure out why you can't get your gut back in order.
Somebody told me I had leaky gut, I had taken probiotics for a long time, and I still have
gut problems, it just has never gotten back in order, I still have inflammation in my gut,
my digestions off, I just can't figure out why I can't get better.
This is one of the reasons why we do these gene tests, because it gives us some answers
to things.
Well, then we look at your gene tests, and you got a single allele, or I've had people with
a double allele defect, and every one of the FUT2 genes, oh my gosh, no wonder you're going
to have a bad gut.
You got on top of that then, a probiotics that you took, and eating genetically modified
foods, and eating junk foods, and additives, calories, flavorings, things like that, and
you're toast.
So what are you going to do?
You have to heal the gut, so go back to my gut check video, and understand that if you have
any defects in your FUT2 genes, you need to be on prebiotics for sure.
Just likely your whole life, be on prebiotics, be on probiotics, on a long-term basis, now
take a step back.
Let's say a person has no defects here, that's the person that they might have a best-up
gut because they took antibiotics, and because they had a poor diet, but it's easier for
them to recover.
So they get on prebiotics for a month or two, they start taking probiotics, their gut is normal
and they're feeling great.
Pretty much guaranteed, they don't have a whole lot of defects in the FUT2 genes.
But a person that's, gosh, I've been working on my gut for the last year and I can't seem
to get better, you probably got some defects.
So you understand how this all comes together a little bit?
So it gives you some answers, so you don't think you're crazy sometimes, so it can really
help looking at your genes and it helps you manage it.
That way that, wow, I, this person, have a single little defect on my FUT2 genes, I'm
going to need to be on prebiotics and probiotics the rest of my life, I'm going to need to watch
my diet more closely, I'm going to need to stay away from antibiotics, I'm going to need
to make different health decisions that way, it helps you manage your life, let's move on.
There's two variants that influence histamine levels, so there's two genes in your body that
degrade histamine, now understand, histamine is an immune cell, excuse me, is it a immune
chemokine made by your mast cells, that is part of your immune system, histamine is needed
to help kill things and remove pathogens, but it's supposed to be secreted by mast cells
and it's supposed to be that degraded quite quickly, literally within a few minutes by these
specific genes, your ABP1 gene family, and there's one, two, three, four, five that are measured
here, in your ABP1 family, these genes degrade histamine in your gut, so how would I get histamine
in my gut? Well histamine is an immune cell, the mast cell secretes histamine, also there's
histamines in different foods, so foods create a histamine reaction, so let's go back to glute
in a second, so if I'm going to eat a lot of glute when I have antibodies to glute, I'm going
to increase my histamine level in my gut, and I'm going to need plenty of healthy ABP1
genes to make an enzyme, the DAO enzyme, that degrades histamine in my gut and breaks it down,
so I don't have this inflammatory process going on in my gut, now histamine is only one of the
inflammatory chemokines, so don't get me wrong, just because like this person doesn't really have
very many variants at all, doesn't have defects at all, I would say ignore your histamine issues
to this individual, that doesn't mean that they're not making other inflammatory cytokines
from a glute sensitivity because they have glute antibodies, so that's another piece of the puzzle,
but in this case this person has one single allele defect in one of their ABP1 genes,
not a problem, guarantee you this person does not have a histamine problem,
the second gene, the HNMT gene, actually makes the enzyme in the body, in the
intracellular, or excuse me, extracellular spaces, so that it breaks down histamine in your body,
because histamine is, that cells are releasing histamine in your body to kill pathogens all the time,
and the HNMT gene is responsible to make the enzyme that degrades histamine in your body,
so if, so let's pretend this is you, and let's pretend in the ABP gene, you have multiple defects there,
that would tell me that you do not make a DAO enzyme that breaks down histamine, you're got very well
so that my recommendation would be, you have to decrease the amount of histamines that you consume,
and make sure that you're not consuming any foods that you have antibodies against,
so a Syrex pedal would probably, the lab would probably be in order to see if you have any antibodies
to any different foods, testing you with conhesiology, whatever we need to do to find out,
any sensitivities that you have to foods that you need to stay away from, and then looking at a list
of foods that contain histamine, eggs, fermented foods, nuts of all types, cheeses, things like that,
that have high amounts of histamine in it, that is throwing histamine into your gut, that you don't
create the enzyme ticket rate of, so you can't be eating foods that have histamine if you can't get
rid of histamine in your gut, you will absorb it, you will cause this histamine reaction in your
body, and you're going to have all sorts of problems, and that could be, so again, with a gene profile,
you could go, wow, this is your reaction, this is why you're so hyperinflammatory, this is why you have
rashes, this is why you have heart palpitations, this is why you have gut problems, this is why you have
migrates, those are all symptoms of histamine, if, like in this case, this person has an HNMT gene
that his whole gene profile is pretty normal there, I mean you could get much better than that,
but let's say in your profile, you had multiple gene defects in the HNMT gene, you can't get rid
of histamine in your body, so you better not be consuming histamine, so that you're absorbing it,
then creating an increased histamine reaction, and you better find out that you're not, and you
haven't autoimmune disorder, that you're going to be producing a whole lot of histamine as well,
and you need to do some things, some nutritional approaches to degrade histamine extracellularly,
meaning in the body, and get it out of your body, does it all make sense though?
Because too much histamine, everything in your life is a balance, everything from a biochemical
process in your body is a balance, it's all about this delicate balance, you need histamine,
it's good for you, but you need to be able to get rid of it, because it's bad for you
if there's too much of it, so it's all about that balance and if you have a genetic
variant that doesn't allow you to keep that balance, then you need to help manipulate that balance
so that you can bring health back, so it's a good invaluable test,
move it on, genetic variants that may impact cell health and cell energy production,
so this set of genes helps you get nutrients into the cell, breakdown fats and carbohydrates
and proteins into end products to go through glycolysis and go through the crem cycle so that you
can make energy, you could say that you're one life's purpose, you know, you have several life's
purpose, right? Well, write this one down, what are your life's purpose is to make acetylcholidzyme?
So next time you're in a class and you say, somebody asks you what your life purpose is, you say,
well, it's to make acetylcholidzyme, later you're going to see it's to make SAM2, but acetylcholidzyme is
what comes out of glycolysis and feeds it to the crem cycle and makes all sorts of ATP,
if you remember, for your biology class in high school, and that is essential for you to have energy.
Now this person has multiple defects in that area, so in this gene that makes
cartotene, acety and the SLC gene, and you can't see that ACS gene that I deleted, it couldn't
fit on the slide down there, boy, they got a mess of defects. So with this mess of defects they have,
I could tell, without even knowing this person's history, I could say this person's going to have
chronic fatigue, they can't help but have chronic fatigue. So remember I said, starting off this
presentation, that just because you have all these gene profile defects, if you have all these defects,
doesn't mean you're going to be a mess. However, if you've got a lot of defects, you can get a pretty
good picture. So in this case, with all these defects, they're going to have a hard time making ATP.
So granted, now if you add Lyme disease or you add cancer or you add some other dysfunction
on top of that, it's going to accelerate this problem and it just literally blow it up.
That's the case with this individual. They have a lot of symptoms because of that. So they don't
make a lot of energy. So supporting this pathway with some specific nutrients is going to really help
them. So then you don't, now we don't. So now we don't, you don't make a fetal coincide. We need to
really help support that path, push that pathway and really help that person with their symptoms.
That makes sense so far. All right, it's still with me. I know it's a lot to go over. So I've had to listen
to this a couple times and we're going to go over yours specifically. So write down your questions.
Next pathway, detoxification, kind of important to detoxify. Remember, your level of toxicity is
depended to put your ability to detoxify. So if you are detoxifying yourself at a rate greater than
your rate of detoxification, you are going to be a sick person. So how do we know I could detoxify
very well? Well, detoxification does have to do with your genetic picture. It has to do with other
things too. Where's my stress level at, et cetera, but we're looking at gene profiles here.
So some of your detoxification pathways are in your SOD pathway. So the first gene that we want to
look at, we're talking about detoxifying, is superoxide dissipatease. I think I got another slide on
this. Let's just let's switch to this other slide from superoxide dissipatease because this is
kind of important, especially when you deal with Lyme patients. Superoxide dissipatease is a gene
aptly named because what it makes is an enzyme called superoxide dissipatease. So the SOD gene
makes SOD. And the whole purpose of SOD superoxide dissipatease is to take superoxide
and turn it into hydrogen peroxide, which then turns into water and your body excretes it.
What's superoxide? Well, superoxide is a byproduct of your body's metabolism. It is necessary.
It's actually a free radical, but before you call it bad, beber, life is a balance. And you need
free radicals in your body because free radicals can help kill pathogens. So this free radical,
superoxide kills pathogens, but you only want it in solution for a very short period of time.
And we don't want that to build up. Well, it's not going to because God made us with a gene called SOD
that makes superoxide dissipatease that actually will degrade any excess superoxide,
turn it into hydrogen peroxide, which other enzymes turn it into water and we pee it out of our body.
Yay, we got rid of it. So it's this cycle, this balance of life, that is so beautiful.
The problem is, is what if I have a defect on my SOD gene? What if I am a double oleal defect on all
three of my SOD genes? Oh, that kind of sticks. Why? Because I'm going to have a buildup of superoxide.
That can be damaging to my cells, buildup of superoxide. But I'm sorry, it gets worse. If you have an
excess of nitric oxide, specifically inducible, cytokine inducible nitric oxide, it will bind to this
excess superoxide and you get peroxidite trait. That's what circled there. The O, N, O, O,
negative is peroxidite trait. That is a very damaging, free radical. It's very harmful to
your cells, causes a lot of fatigue, causes brain damage, etc. This is the perfect picture of a
line patient. So this is what I see a lot of my line patients have. Well, a lot of my line
patients are very ill line patients. So they're very ill because they have lots of things going on.
Well, we want to blame it all on the line. Well, there's other things going on too. It's very common
with a line patient to see a defect in the SOD, SOD gene. So the profile looks like this. These are the
SOD genes. This person has a single allele defect at all three of those genes. So they certainly have
a decreased function of the SOD gene. So it's not making enough superoxide dispatase. It's keeping
an excess amount of superoxide in the tissues. And then it's created a lot of peroxidite trait. Why?
Because see this itto? This is nitric oxide with line patients.
Line is a chronic infection. So it's not just line patients with chronic H-pylori patients,
with chronic subclinical viral patients. They're producing an excess amount of a specific type
of nitric oxide, which there's three main types of nitric oxide. Itted a chronic infection. You'll
produce an excess amount of what's called cytokine inducible nitric oxide through cytokine inducible
nitric oxide synthase. This will be circulating through the blood. It will combine with the superoxide
and make an excess amount of peroxidite trait. This is what could be very damaging. And this is what
causes line brain. This is what causes the achiness, the pain, that moves around in your body that
nobody conceived to understand. Most these people, so you got two types of line patients. I had chronic
line, but I just took cat's call and I'm just fine. I don't know what's wrong with you. They probably
don't have a lot of genetic defects that we're talking about here. Then you got the other type of
person that's got a lot of genetic defects, especially in the SOD gene and some other that we're
going to talk about later. They're producing a ton of peroxidite trait causing symptoms.
We want to look at these things because you could support this pathway and you could really help this
so they're not getting this much of this. There's products that can help scavenge peroxidite trait and
grab onto it and get it out of the body. Doei, this can be invaluable to some of these chronically
ill patients. It's just a great thing to know. Back here, looking at this gene profile, Doei,
you have these variants can be super, super helpful. Next one is glutathione production. Let's see if
it's in this picture. Cut it out in this corner. I cut it off, but glutathione is recycled in your
body. It's oxidized, reduced, you're recycling glutathione around this loop over and over again,
and glutathione is your primary antioxidant in your body. It oxidizes a whole bunch of other
chemicals and garbage that you've got to get rid of. This person has three defects that are going
to affect those. They're single allele defects and these are a factor thing, so not a terrible thing
with glutathione for this person. I've seen much worse than that. Now as we move down, the CYP
genes are your cytochrome P450 pathways. Your cytochrome P450 pathways are essential at your
primary detoxification pathway. This person has multiple defects in their cytochrome P450 pathway.
They're going to be a slower detoxer overall, and then your pod pathway that's kind of cut off
down at the bottom of this screen is, at least right now, the research is showing, that's how we
detoxify chemicals, multiple drugs, pesticides, herbicides, et cetera. It's not uncommon to see
a bunch of defects in that pod pathway. People with defects in their pod pathway have to be very careful
that they're buying. They're making sure that they're buying that the dirty dozen foods that
have the highest rate of or highest content of pesticides and chemicals and things that you
should buy organic. You need to really be really tight on making sure you're staying away from
pesticides and herbicides and things like that. If you have defects in your pod pathway,
so again, you can see how knowledge can help make decisions in your life and it can help keep
you healthy. Doing pretty well so far? Not overwhelmed with you? That's not so bad, is it? So again,
this is just a picture of some of those pathways. This is part of the transolpheration pathway right
here. So this homelessness is coming from the methionate pathway up here through CBS's feeding down
to glutathione, and what's out of this picture is the Krebs cycle and where you make your energy.
Now let's move to the folate pathway. So if you're lucky enough to do this whole
going over your test at my office that I could kind of show you some charts and wear these fitted
and maybe I'm the only one that fights as fascinating, but oh well. So your folate pathway, the
purpose of your folate pathway really is to make methyl tetrahydrofolate. And maybe one of the most
research of these genes is the methyl tetrahydrofolate reductase gene. That's a family of several
genes the most important is the one right down here, the MTHFRC677T, and that's probably one of
the more research genes. And this poor soul has a double allele defect of that gene. So
the research of this gene, the MTHFRC677T, if you have a double allele defect of this gene,
it's going to slow your detoxification processes about 60 to 70%. Now that's a very important thing
to know. This is where we get into some philosophical questions like, should I vaccinate my child?
Well if I do, my child has a 677 double allele defect, there's a way you should vaccinate your child.
So I don't care if you believe that vaccines cause autism or not, but using medication as the
mother, if you do, that you had a MTHFR defect and know that since you have a double allele defect,
your child has at least a single allele defect. If you do what your gene profile was, of the father
was, then you'd have a real good idea of what the child says, at least you could do a little graph
and figure it out. You better make, this really should help you make some better decisions
because, okay, so here's a mom, let's use a scenario here. A mother does her gene profile. She knows,
she has multiple cytochrome P450 pathway defects in some of these other pictures that we saw,
some pod defects. She does, she has an SOD defect. At this she has a double allele defect of her MTHFR.
There's no way I'm taking medications while I'm pregnant. You got to figure out a natural approach
to do this. And there's no way you're going to take medications delivering this baby because you
are setting this little six-pound baby up for all sorts of disasters because they're not going to be
able to get rid of things out of their body, meeting drugs, chemicals, vaccines, etc., very well
at all, period. And these are the kids that end up having braid issues because of
choices, that medication, vaccinations, etc., versus a child who has got zero defects of this,
they could get vaccinated. It goes right through them. They, you know, get out of their diaper.
There's no issues whatsoever. So do vaccines cause autism? No. But do vaccines and
chemicals and additives, colorings, flavorings, everything. Can they cause autism? Well, if you are
that slow of a detoxer, it's going to be circulated through your body. It's going to cross the blood
braid barrier, especially in a child where their blood braid barrier isn't even fully formed for
several years. And you think that's not going to cause problems in the braid? You are dreaming.
So knowing these genetic profiles can really shape the decisions you make. This is science. This is
some philosophy of a natural doctor or something like that. Anybody that denies this is denied a lot
of research. So you have to be kind of have your head of the sand to not deal with these issues.
All right. This is your folate pathway. You eat leaf good cooked leafy greens. I go through
these genes all the way down here. The MTHFR gene is what we're just talking about. It's made
purposes to make five methyl tetrahedral folate feeds into the MTR gene that feeds this way. That's
not on this picture. That's the methionine cycle goes through the cycle of MTR, MTRR, which recycles B12.
feeds into the methionine cycle that makes SAME. This methyl tetrahedral folate then feeds
down this way to the myopterine cycle. And this is constantly going on in your cells. This is feeding
yourselves. Little side note, so I don't have to repeat it when I'm talking to you in person,
makes sure absolutely you never ever ever take folic acid. Now, you could never ever get away
from folic acid because they put it in so many foods. But certainly don't buy vitamins that have
folic acid in them. Folic acid is synthetic folate. Folate is what is found in green leafy vegetables.
Folic acid is what's created in a laboratory. Folic acid is hypothesized to be actually one of the
causative factors of a methyl tetrahedral folate reductase defect. So the defects that we were
talking about here, like this person who has a double allele defect in the MTHFR gene,
can be caused from consuming folic acid. Now, remember, go back to some of these other genetic
presentations that I've done. These are epigenetic defects that some of these defects are believed
to have been in the gene pool for thousands of years and some are protective, some have to do with
environmental issues that our ancestors were exposed to. These are epigenetic defects.
Some, like this MTHFR defect, is believed to be caused because of synthetic folic acid
being introduced to the 20s and 30s. And it's still in a vogue today, even though there's literally
hundreds, maybe thousands of research articles sharing the danger of using folic acid.
Still, it's in multiple supplements. So it's just stay away from it, like the plague, all right?
Next, all right. So now we're looking at the MTHFR pathway, the way you recycle B12. So this MTHR,
right there, came from right here, folate in your food. You reduce it to methyl tetrahedral
folate. It goes back to feed this pathway, goes on to the biopterate pathway. This is what we're
looking at now, feed it in right there, to the pathiety pathway, another life purpose you have that you
didn't know about to make SAME. SAME is your made methyl transferase for your entire body. So that is
what helps you make new cells, create DNA and methylate. When you methylation process within the cell
helps you turn on and off genes that you don't want to be on. Or you need to turn on, you would
remove the methyl group. So very, very, very important. So in this case scenario, this MTHR gene,
this person has a single allele defect, the MTHRR gene, this person has a single allele defect.
These are all the genes that feed into factors of a person needing help with vitamin B12.
Why did we add the FUT2 genes here? Because that person has a single allele defect in all those genes.
Why? Because where do you get vitamin B12? Well, you're supposed to absorb it through your gut,
right? Well, where do you get it? Where do you get it? It's from red meat. So you eat red meat that has
good vitamin B12 in there. It binds to intrinsic factor in your stomach and in your gut, you absorb it.
Well, if I have defects in my gut's ability to create a good mucosa layer, that I'm not going
to be a good absorber of B12. Plus, I have defects in my MTHR and MTHRR gene. So I don't recycle B12
very well. That kind of tells us that this person is going to need to be a B12,
most likely to help them, not only help them absorb it better, but help them recycle it. So they're
on a comolamine, methyl comolamine, a denticel comolamine, hydroxy comolamine, depended upon their symptom
picture. That's what's necessary to feed into methionine. Let's move on. Then there's the PEMT
and the BHMT gene, go back to this picture right here. This is the BHMT gene right here. So
as we move through the cycle and you make methionine, again, that has to go through the MAT gene, which
we're going to talk about just a second, in order to convert to SAM. So SAM, that is your
made-methyl transverse for your entire body. Then it converts to SOH, because it's all a valence.
Oh, we got too much SAMH. We're going to make SOH. That goes through the AHCY gene to a
homocysteine. And the homocysteine is shunted up. It's recycled again through the BHMT gene to
methionine, to make more SAMH. It's going in this pretty little circle. We're making SAMH,
as we need to make SAMH. Oh no, we have a defect. Well, we don't recycle homocysteine very well,
because why? Because we have a BHMT defect. Matter of fact, we got to double a little defect in two
of the four genes. Oh no, that's not good. We're not making SAMH very well. What's going to be the symptom
picture in this person? Well, it could be more fatigue. This could be more even like brain fog
fatigue too. A whole bunch of symptoms that go along with SAMH, so I don't want to simplify that.
But we have to talk about that with this person, and how could we support the BHMT pathway?
Again, we can't change the genetic picture, but we could help support this pathway with nutrients
that help push it. Does that make sense? And that's not the only picture. We got to look at other
things that could block it. Does this person have a heavy metal toxicity? Do they have a cortisol
issue? Do they have a lipopolysaccharide? Well, when they do, they have a lipopolysaccharide issue,
because they have a chronic Lyme. So we got to kill the chronic Lyme 2. Is this fun? Well,
not if it's me, that's what you're probably saying. The next, the GMT, AHCM, and the MAT gene.
We started talking about those. This may be the most important. This MAT gene,
they certainly is for this individual, because they have a double allele defect in one, two,
three, four, five of the eight genes. Oh, that stinks. Yes, it does. Because they don't convert
methionine to SAMH. And we already saw that they had a defect out here at the BHMT. So even if they
are converting some homocysteine to methionine, it's not really getting the SAMH very well.
Oogh. Definitely need some magnesium. Definitely need some ATP. Of course, they don't make ATP very good.
No wonder this person isn't in my office. No wonder they feel so gruddy.
It gets kind of frustrated, doesn't it? Well, this is what makes my job so difficult,
because there's so many different things to fix on this person. If you ignore them, you ignore them
to your own peril. So you have to look under every stone to figure this out. So that's what's so
important when you deal with these patients. You got to look at the big picture, as big a picture as
you possibly can. All right, so that's that gene profile. Now we move into the neurotransmitters.
This is where it gets really fun. I haven't fun yet. Folks, isn't this exciting? Boy, this is going
a long time and I've tried to talk fast. Oh, all right. So let's widen it down here. Let's talk about
your neurotransmitters. So everybody thinks about the brain with neurotransmitters, but you'd have to
have neurotransmitters everywhere, right? Because everywhere your nerves come in contact with another
nerve, that's how they communicate through these little chemicals we call neurotransmitters.
So let's talk about these. First one, serotonin. So serotonin is what? Your happy neurotransmitter?
Well, it's much more than that. But serotonin is degraded through bow. Let's look at it on this picture here.
This is your biopterid pathway, isn't it, pretty? So I have to shout out to Dr. Badlidge who made
these pathway planners. Great guy. So they came for these beautiful pictures. I like pretty pictures
like anybody else. So this is biopterid recycling. Hopefully you can see my cursor here.
Biopterid goes down through fetalality, tyrosine, tryptophan. And it feeds down to serotonin down
here at the bottom. And you can see the mau down here. Mau M-A-O is how you degrade serotonin.
It is a Y chromosome defect. So men can only have a single allele defect. Women can have a double
allele defect. And typically, we think of that defect. Typically, we think a lot of these defects as
blocking that pathway. So that is the right way to think most of the time. But in lots of cases,
it can either block or speed. In this case, it can do that. So serotonin is degraded through mau.
That's how you get rid of serotonin. You need to make serotonin. We need serotonin. But we have to
degrade it. We can't have too much serotonin. So we have this enzyme called the mau enzyme,
which then degrade serotonin. However, if I have a mau defect, I can either degrade it too quickly
so that I have too little serotonin. Or I can degrade it too slowly. And then I have too much
serotonin. So what happens in both these people with these defects? They have times that they have too
little and they have times they have too much. And here would be my symptom picture if this was me.
If I have too little serotonin, I'm sad. And I'm maybe even a little depressed. And I just have
some melancholy. And I have some sadness. If I have too little, I'm a little irritable. And I'm a
little quick tempered. And I'm a little short with people. So I could tell a lot about you when I
look at your gene profile. Because the next gene we talk about is dopamine up here. And the comp gene,
the COMT gene. So dopamine, hopefully you can see by cursor. It's at the upper right hand side. You see
dopamine. And that's degraded through COMT. Also, norapidephrine is, also through moh, norapidephrine.
And epidephrine is degraded through COMT. The COMT gene could do just the same. It could speed or
I could slow. But it usually slows the degradation of that neurotransmitter. The comp defect is much
researched with ADD, ADHD kids that are seen to have, in common, to have a comp defect.
So they have an excess amount of dopamine. They tend to be a little bit more aggressive. They tend
to be very stuck on things. It's hard for them to focus. It's hard for them to stay focused. They
get distracted, easy. They're impulsive. And they can be OCD. So that is the picture of a comp defect patient.
So you add a comp defect with a bow defect and a gad defect. Gad is how you get rid of, or how you
create GABA. Now you add a gad defect. So GABA is actually a call me neurotransmitter. If rings
call, you need a lot of GABA to go to sleep at night and rest. The person that has a healthy GABA
production is calm and understanding and can talk through things. When I have gad defects,
I'm quick tempered. I'm angry. And it's really hard for my brain to chill out and calm down. And
I tend to be pro to anxiety. So here's a person, this individual, doesn't have the bow defect, but
I have my patients with a double allele bow defect, three cup defects and multiple gad defects.
I could pretty much tell you their temperament. So this gives you some answers. Then you look at
the pathway and you go, well, how do I fix this? Well, how you fix this a lot is by tempering the
diet. How I have a whole paper I wrote on how to balance the cup and bow defects.
And I'm constantly adding to it. So it's just a way to look at, you look at what feeds it,
fetalality, tyrosine, triptophid. These are amino acids. Maybe it's not really good if I have
a cup and bow defect to be eaten a ton of chicken and turkey and fish and meat and such that are
going to add these amino acids. At least don't eat them without eating a lot of fibrous vegetables.
Maybe I need to cut down on the meats a little bit and eat more vegetables. I'd be doing, I might do
much better. Still with me? Because I could get more complicated. You look at this whole pathway,
this ideal pathway over here. This is what I call the triptophid steel. Especially in the presence of
playful polysaccharides. What's that? That's a byproduct of the breakdown of
grabedeginibacteria like libe disease, the bernorpy bacteria, the
H-pylori, i-N-F gamma, T-N-F alpha. Those are inflammatory cytokines. So the presence of
chronic inflammation, stress, emotional stress, triptophid gets stolen down the ideopathway.
This is the chyrridid pathway. Chyrridid forms eventually chryllidic acid, which could be an
excitotoxin. And this could cause depression, inflammation of the brain, all sorts of problems.
So this is where you get an autoimmune reaction, this ramped-up inflammation of the brain,
it damaged the neurons and glial cells, and brain fog. So it could kind of be a mess, right?
So in cases like this, we really have to watch the proteins that were consuming, in the amino acids
that were consuming, that were not feeding this whole pathway. That if this person has a mild
defector, they're not degrading serotonin, and they have a lot of aggression, we don't certainly
want to be producing more serotonin. Look at the bottom of this, the bottom right hand side,
melatonin. Oh, that's a byproduct of serotonin, but it's not degrading very well at all. We got
excess serotonin. It's feeding back up here. We got the adiosteal, the triptophane
steel going on, making chryllidic acid. I'm not making melatonin, that's why I can't fall asleep.
You see how this answers a lot of questions? You thought you were just crazy? Well, you might
still be crazy, but at least you know why you're crazy, no? So this genetic pathway properly understood,
and I understand I know nothing compared to what I hope to know in a year. It really can answer
some questions on why I have symptoms and what's going on. Does this help in you? Then you have the
NOS gene that degrades and creates nitric oxide. Remember I said there's three forms of nitric oxide.
There's NOS1, or what's called cytokine inducible nitric oxide. That's what's ramped up in a
chronic infection, what's ramped up in an acute infection too, but it's that it's supposed to degrade.
But what I have a chronic infection that I have this constantly ramped up
nitric oxide, cytokine inducible nitric oxide, or NOS1, which can bind to superoxide, if I have an SOD
variant, it cause peroxidite trait problems, right? That's not good. And then there's NOS2,
which is essential and important. I understand NOS1 is important and essential, but we don't want to
have excess amounts of it. It'll ramp up chronic infection state. So again, it's everything is
balanced. NOS2 is found in the brain, and that's protective and neuroprotective for the brain.
NOS3 is also called endothelial nitric oxide. The endothelial cell is the cell that
lines your blood vessels. That is absolutely essential to your blood vessels or the health of your
blood vessels. And a deficiency in NOS3 or endothelial nitric oxide is your cause of high blood pressure
and leads to cardiovascular disease. You add that to these additional cardiovascular support
genes, the ACE gene. This person has a defect in the ACE gene. This person is really going to be
prone here to high blood pressure and cardiovascular disease and needs support in that area.
So this person, this very person I can't remember, but they could say, well, I don't have high blood
pressure. Well, you don't have high blood pressure. You don't know you have cardiovascular disease,
but you definitely don't make as much endothelial nitric oxide and you have issues with your ACE
genes that make the receptor that will decrease your blood pressure. We certainly want to support
that arena now before you end up having a problem. Does that make sense? So knowing these things prior
to having a disease can be really helpful and help you make decisions to help monitor your life.
This next gene is also really, all these genes are important, but this one is really important,
especially if I can't say patients, this vitamin D receptor gene, this VDR gene, there's three
genes that we measure in this gene family. And this person is pretty shot here. They got a
single allele defected two of them and a double allele defected one of them. So this person does not make
that, there's, if they have a difficult time getting vitamin D where it's needed into the cell,
into the bone, they don't have as many receptors. Remember, the vitamin D receptors also function as
an apoptosis receptor to help prevent cell not going through apoptosis, which leads to cancer.
So I want my patients that have this gene defect to have blood vitamin D levels, if they measure
their vitamin D levels, certainly over 80. Matter of fact, if you added over 100, I'd be much more
happier because they need to have much higher vitamin, circulated vitamin D levels, blood tested
vitamin D levels because they have a receptor defect. So with this gene defect, you want to really
up your, up your vitamin D levels. If you haven't gotten a tested, you can get your vitamin D blood tested,
not a very expensive test, but this person certainly needs to be a 5 to 10 to 15,000 I use a vitamin D
a day. This helpful so far? All sorts of things to learn about your gene defect. And then this
my computer program puts this, this BH4 is biopterid. Biopterid has to do with your mood, has to do
with your nitric oxide too. So let's go back to this pathway here. Biopterid recycling, so biopterid
is recycled here. And it moves around this cycle like this, feeding, creating neurotransmitters,
creating nitric oxide, see this is E and OS, that's NOS3, same thing, endothelial nitric oxide here.
And it's so important for your heart, it's so important for your neurotransmitters, it's important for
your brain, it's just really important, isn't it? So defects in that affect your mood, it also affects
your heart. So important cardiovascular features. Still with me? Is this fun? Well, we're at the end.
So at the end, then after I go through all of this with you, I figure out based upon your ratings
on all those genes, a protocol for you. So your protocol is based upon those genes, I decide what we
need to do to support those pathways. I can't change the genes, but we can certainly support the pathways.
It has to do with your personal symptoms, as well as what's going on with your gene profile.
So in this case, we're going to use a protocol B specific, and a B specific, that specific vitamin
has your B support without the methylation support, because we can't support
methylation first with this person, because they have so many defects in the biopterid pathway,
that if we push methylation too hard, this is what we see a lot with patients. They come in
in there, taking something that because they'd ran one gene test, and they have a MTHFR or G
defect, so the doctor put them on high doses of methyl tetrahedral folate, and that's not a good
way to do it, because if you have other G defects, no, because they had all that circulating
five methyl tetrahedral folate, it pushes everything else, and this person had a ton of defects
in the biopterid pathway. You can't add methylation support right away, so we're supporting their cell
health because of the issues with fatigue, and the issues with their ability to make energy. That's
why we're giving mitochondrial support. You need minerals for all those pathways, and we're
supporting SOD, because one of the biggest problems this person had was brain fog and brain fatigue
from excess peroxidite trait. So remember, that's from an SOD defect, so we have to support the SOD,
and I could have used a peroxidite trait scavenger with this person too, but I don't like to use
too many supplements at one time, and we just want to make sure things are going, and we have to tweak
this and play with it, and it's not something that they're going to be on the rest of their life,
it might be there only going to be on for a month or two, and we need to change things.
It's hard when you have genetic defects, it's affected so many pathways, so you have to tweak the
program. It's not like here's this cookie cutter thing, it just doesn't work that way, so you have
to be patient with yourself, and that's how we'll all be happy because you're a person, and your
body's changing all the time. So if you have questions, if you're watching this video, you don't
even know who I am. My name is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and that's our website Cutters Clinic up there,
so if you somehow stumbled across it and stumbled your way through it, I congratulate you.
If you want more information about our clinic, you can contact us. If you're watching this video,
most likely I made you watch this video, and if you're still here, I will give you a cookie,
because you watched the whole thing. So good job. If you need to watch it a couple times, do so,
and I look forward to talking to you about your test. All right, thanks. Bye-bye.